to the moon the Troy salsa I'm a trainer
chance trained some of the best regular
Watson shannon minx I haven't checked
check Russia
thanks for all potential champions who
didn't goddamn listen I don't know
motivator from the other side of town
okay give my men to fight ways they
didn't think we're possible now I'd like
to take someone who I know can make look
there's a look in the fighters eyes says
yes Teddy I'm listening you do not ask
questions
yo goddamn James and I'm gonna be a
champ make you rich if I get bruised up
on the way so what got how about jackets
in my car best goddamn cut man in the
business
that's a look that says that goddamn it
right now how they're not training the
future champion Kenny
spare tire sparrow what's the guy in the
trunk what's the guy in the trunk prayer
breakfast it's a Thursday every month
damn Kenny what are you doing right Oh a
culture we like them now I guess the
tated on the jump rope you can charge
that to the game but I just did right
there
give me that I'm smoke I'll see you all
right Denny kill the cutover a tie with
a wrist corsage and lower bicuspid